in the quiet heart of a small town
ripped apart there are now 21 crosses
your heart father allow that you vow to
be back to normal where they can trust
the good god because you are a good god
and a faith that must now carry a broken
community and we believe that you value
is destined to be a city of glory
among them parents who know it could
have been their children
and then how do you explain all this to
them
over the street in the calm of his
office one among so many who witnessed
such horror this photo here was you it
was this yesterday
that was this morning this morning
and what was hap what was happening here
it was just a tough time a moment
eulalio diaz is the official whose job
it became to identify the young victims
this is not normal life this is not the
way it's supposed to happen my job is to
be a corner for the county when it's
needed
but never for 21
people that were
massacred at a school that's not what i
signed up to do that's not what i
expected to do but i have to do it
alongside all the grief for the
questions about guns and the gunman of
course but the police response to and
security at the school
he walked in uninstructed initially so
from
the grandmother's house to the barbadge
to the school
into the school
he was not confronted by anybody
officers revealed the school's back door
might have been unlocked
for the families who pleaded with police
to go into the school as it all unfolded
they have promised a full investigation
[Music]
and then there are the bigger central
questions
texas senator ted cruz was among the
mourners last night a republican who has
received more money than any other from
the gun lobby which seeks to influence
policy why does this only happen in your
country i really think that's what many
people around the world just
they cannot fathom why only in america
why is this american exceptionalism so
awful
you know i'm sorry you think american
exceptionalism is awful i think this
aspect i think this aspect of it
you get your political agenda no it's us
god love you senator it's not i just
want to understand why you do not think
that guns are the problem why is this
just an american problem well it is just
an american problem sir mr cruz why is
america the only country that faces this
kind of you know what mass shooting but
you can't answer that you can't answer
that can you say you can't answer that
why is this why is it that people come
from all over the world to america
because it's the freest most prosperous
safest country maybe
irma garcia was one of the two teachers
shot with her pupils now tragedy upon
tragedy her husband joe has suffered a
fatal heart attack
they were high school sweethearts and
married for 24 years
they leave behind four children
mark stone sky news in uvalde texas